auteur de la proposition de loi pour 10
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues nous examinons aujourd'hui la
proposition de loi visant à adapter la
défense extérieure contre l'incendie à
la réalité des territoires ruraux je
remercie le groupe de l'Union centriste
d'avoir demandé son inscription dans
l'espace qui lui réservait ce texte est
le fruit des travaux de la délégation
collectivité territoriale initiée à la
demande du président du Sénat qui a
considéré je le cite qu'il n'est pas
normal que la quasi-totalité du budget
d'investissement d'une commune soit
consacrée à la défense extérieure contre
l'incendie quel que soit l'importance de
celle-ci ces travaux ont été menés avec
mon collègue Franck Montauger que je
salue et ils ont abouti à la publication
en juillet 2021 du rapport défense
extérieures contre l'incendie assurait
la protection des personnes s'ennuient
au territoire
le Sénat a débattu en séance publique le
5 janvier 2022 à la demande de la
délégation collectivité territoriale
présidée par notre collègue Françoise
Gatel également auteur de cette
proposition de loi que je tiens à
remercier pour son appui tout au long de
nos travaux au cours de ce débat de
janvier 2022 nous avons malheureusement
constaté à quel point le gouvernement
n'était pas conscient de la situation et
de ses conséquences sur un grand nombre
de territoires ruraux ce constat nous a
conduit à déposer la proposition de loi
que nous examinons aujourd'hui
à notre initiative l'article 32 de la
loi du 21 février 2022 dit 3DS a prévu
que le gouvernement remet un rapport
d'évaluation de l'impact de la défense
extérieure contre l'incendie sur les
communes et ce avant le 1er juillet 2022
si celui-ci n'a pas été formellement
remis par le gouvernement comme le
prévoit la loi ce qui est quelque peu
surprenant une copie de ce rapport daté
de juin 2022 m'a été remise récemment à
la demande du cabinet du ministre de
l'Intérieur
nous nous félicitons que ce document
confirme une très grande partie des
conclusions auxquelles nous sommes
arrivés avec Franck Montauger même si
curieusement il a été élaboré sans
aucune consultation des maires mais
uniquement des préfets
il est tout d'abord nécessaire de
rappeler que la loi du 17 mai 2011 a
substitué à la réglementation nationale
en matière de défense extérieure contre
l'incendie le principe d'une
réglementation départementale établie
par le préfet en concertation avec les
élus locaux l'objectif étant de mieux
répondre aux spécificités des différents
territoires que ne peut le faire une
réglementation nationale
comme le souligne l'excellent rapport de
notre collègue Loïc Hervé rapporteur
pour la commission des lois que je tiens
à remercier pour la qualité de nos
échanges et de son travail cette réforme
était attendue de longue date par les
élus et les parlementaires
malheureusement près de 12 ans après
l'adoption de cette loi force est de
constater que celle-ci n'a pas répondu à
leurs attentes et à la volonté du
législateur quant à l'adaptation de ces
règles à la réalité des territoires elle
a au contraire provoqué dans un certain
nombre de départements un fort
mécontentement des mers
celui-ci résulte de la mise en
application très inégale et souvent très
insatisfaisante de la concertation
prévue par le décret de 2015 selon
l'enquête que nous avons menée 70% des
mers estiment en effet que la
concertation n'a pas été satisfaisante
un autre aspect insatisfaisant de la
réforme et l'absence d'évaluation de la
mise en oeuvre au niveau local des
règles de défense extérieures contre
l'incendie celle-ci ont pu en effet être
élaborer sans considération de leurs
conséquences notamment financières pour
les communes chargées de leur
application
il en résulte que ces règlements ne
répondent pas toujours ou insuffisamment
aux spécificités infras départementales
et ne sont pas proportionnés à la
réalité des risques
dans le département de l'Eure que j'ai
l'honneur de représenter cela a conduit
à éditer une règle particulièrement
stricte d'une distance de 200 mètres
entre les habitations et l'installation
d'un poids d'eau sur l'ensemble du
territoire que ce soit en zone urbaine
ou en zone rurale alors que le risque en
termes de propagation n'est évidemment
pas le même
comme l’indique le rapport du
gouvernement je cite il n'est pas
concevable de demander à des communes
peuplées de disposer d'une couverture de
deci
identique à celle des communes urbaines
et pourtant cela peut être le cas je
sais de quoi je parle ce même rapport du
gouvernement va plus loin en indiquant
que ces règlements devraient même
envisager l'absence de couverture plutôt
je cite toujours qu'une dci coûteuse et
pénalisante pour assurer la couverture
incendie d'un bâti à risque très faible
ces règles disproportionnées ont des
conséquences particulièrement
préjudiciables sur les finances des
communes ce sont en effet parfois des
investissements de plusieurs centaines
de milliers d'euros qui sont nécessaires
pour de toutes petites communes
je me permettrai de citer l'exemple de
la commune des bottereaux dans l'Eure
qui compte 380 habitants qui a un budget
de 200000 euros les travaux de mise aux
normes sur son territoire s'élèveraient
à 3 millions 600 000 euros
le rapport du gouvernement rejoint ce
constat en indiquant je cite encore la
récurrence des sinistres en zone rurale
et de faible intensité et les
investissements demandés au maire
paraissent souvent disproportionné par
rapport aux finances de leur
collectivité je ne saurais mieux dire
les maires pour financer ces dépenses de
mise en conformité sont donc contraints
de renoncer à des investissements
importants pour la population et pour
lesquelles il s'était engagés lors des
investis lors des élections municipales
investissement qui de surcroît
bénéficieraient davantage aux
entreprises locales que des bornes
incendies ou des bâches
cette situation conduit de nombreux
mères à devoir refuser toute
autorisation d'urbanisme enclenchant
ainsi un cercle vicieux de baisse de
population et donc de ressources et de
fermeture de classe
si certains préfets conscient des
difficultés ont modifié leur règlement
des départementales de défense
extérieures contre l'incendie pour tenir
compte des attentes des élus cela était
le cas notamment deux fois en
Seine-Maritime ce n'est malheureusement
pas toujours le cas une réponse
législative pour remédier à cette
situation et donc nécessaire et c'est le
sens de la proposition de loi que nous
examinons aujourd'hui et qui a été
enrichi par le travail du rapporteur et
de la commission des lois
ainsi le règlement deviendra un volet du
schéma départemental d'analyse et de
couverture des risques pour renforcer
encore la nécessaire articulation entre
couverture des risques et moyens de
lutte contre les incendies mises à
disposition du 10
la consultation des élus dans le cadre
de l'élaboration du règlement de défense
extérieures contre l'incendie sera
renforcée et élargie le préfet devra
ainsi recueillir la vie des communes et
des intercommunalités lorsqu'elles sont
compétentes en matière de défense
extérieure contre l'incendie et prendre
en compte ses avis une évaluation
préalable de l'application du règlement
dans le département permettant
d'objectiver les difficultés devraient
être faites par ailleurs cette ce
document le règlement départemental
n'ayant pas vocation selon l'expression
du gouvernement que je cite à nouveau à
être figé il me semble nécessaire que
ces règlements puissent être modifiés à
l'issue du vote de cette proposition de
loi s'ils n'ont pas été révisés au cours
des cinq dernières années
cette clause de revoyure doit permettre
l'intégration de bonnes pratiques
l'évolution des techniques et des
risques notamment sous l'effet des
règlements climatiques elle devra
permettre l'édiction également de règles
qui devront respecter plusieurs
principes indispensables premièrement
l'adaptation aux spécificités du
territoire je proposerai ici de préciser
qu'elles doivent avoir un caractère
infradépartemental le nécessaire
équilibre et la complémentarité entre
les moyens des communes et ceux des 10
la prise en compte de l'impact
budgétaire et financier de ces règles
sur les finances communales
comme l'indique le rapport du
gouvernement la fixation de ces règles
en fonction du matériel et des
ressources des 10 malheureusement trop
souvent observés ne peut constituer une
règle absolue
le règlement de défense extérieure
contre l'incendie ne doit pas être la
variable d'ajustement des moyens des
disques mais doit également prendre en
compte je cite une fois encore le
gouvernement la nécessité d'éviter de
faire peser des investissements hors de
proportion sur les budgets des
collectivités enfin ce texte proposera
également l'institution d'une commission
départementale chargée du suivi de
l'application de ses règles il s'agira
d'inscrire dans la loi la création de
cet instance que le ministre de
l'Intérieur a indiqué dans un courrier
qu'il m'a adressé appelé de ses vœux
celle-ci sera composée de mer et présidé
par l'un d'entre eux et sera chargé de
l'évaluation de la mise en oeuvre des
règles dans la matière et de leurs
conséquences en matière budgétaire
d'urbanisme et de développement
économique cette commission pourra
notamment proposée au préfet toute
modification du règlement qui lui sera
qui lui semblera nécessaire quelles sont
mes chers collègues les éléments que je
souhaitais partager avec vous pour vous
présenter cette proposition de loi je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole